Muy bien, estoy editando esta página web en Khan
Academy y, por supuesto, se trata de conejos.
He decidido que quiero editarlo dentro de mi
editor de escritorio. Entonces lo que haré es
seleccionarlo todo y luego copiarlo y luego ir
a mi editor de escritorio, estoy usando Atom,
pero podrías estar usando algún otro editor. A
continuación voy a pegar ese html y veré que todo
haya salido bien. Bien, ahora voy a guardar este
archivo y lo guardaré como 'todo sobre conejos
punto html'. Por lo general es preferible
usar nombres de archivo sin espacios todo en
minúsculas, este es un buen nombre de archivo. Y
podemos ver que cambia el código de colores de las
etiquetas html. Bien, ahora iré a mi navegador
abriré una nueva pestaña y luego abrir archivo,
y buscaré el archivo, lo abro y aquí lo tenemos.
Muestra el archivo de mi sistema de archivos pero
ahora quiero editarlo. Para eso voy a volver a
mi página y escribiré 'adorables conejitos'. Lo
guardo y luego vuelvo al navegador, recargo
la página y aquí está mi cambio. Ahora,
cuando volví a cargar la página hice lo que
se llama una recarga forzada usando el método
abreviado de teclado Control+Shift+R. Una recarga
forzada vuelve a cargar una página y le dice al
navegador que ignore lo que haya almacenado en
caché localmente. A los navegadores a menudo
les gusta conservar las versiones antiguas de
las páginas web para que puedan desplegarlas
más rápido, pero cuando estás depurando lo que
realmente quieres es tener la última versión.
Entonces tienes que hacer una recarga forzada.
Bien, entonces si queremos hacer otro cambio,
hacemos el cambio, lo guardamos, vamos al
navegador, recargamos... ¡ta-dá! Y ese es
generalmente el ciclo cuando usas un editor de
escritorio: vas a hacer el cambio, lo guardas,
vuelves a tu navegador, lo recargas, y simplemente
te acostumbras a hacerlo rápidamente. Ahora,
incluso podrías tener suerte y descubrir que tu
editor tiene una herramienta para previsualizar,
en cuyo caso tu ciclo de edición se
vuelve aún más rápido. Sólo tendrás
que explorar el editor que decidas
usar y ver qué funcionalidad tiene.